we are indeed with atusa percussion
atusa first of all welcome to the St
Louis chess club this is the first time
that you are playing here at the Saint
Louis chess club tell us how do you
enjoy the atmosphere
yes thank you uh yes it's my first time
here
um I've never been to San Luis even
though I'm in the states for a long time
so it was kind of strange and uh uh yeah
it's really nice here I heard a lot of
good things about the club so when I
came here it was really beautiful the
venue and also the big the giant king I
really love that
so yeah everything is great here and one
thing about this tournament a lot of
these players have played against each
other but they haven't played against
you did you feel like that will give you
an advantage going into this event
um I think it's okay because I mean I've
been playing chess since I was eight
years old and my games are in databases
and I used to play in Olympia's many
olympiads so we might have you know
played in international tournaments
uh and actually it was kind of difficult
for me the first day here because I
didn't know the environment and uh it
just kind of uh
happened so quickly especially with the
time control but I think now I'm more or
less adjusting to the environment
definitely felt like you adjusted well
and a big game and a big match between
yourself and Anna zetansky tell us about
this last game assess it for us
explaining to us
yeah I mean uh and I was playing very
well and I couldn't get anything out of
the opening so I thought okay I'm gonna
go to this kind of end game which is a
little bit better for me although the
bishop was not that great because of the
pawn structures
so I just came up with this idea G4
because uh if I don't play G4 then it's
kind of hard to break through so I
thought that I need to get my pawns so
you just want to take more space yes
because the point is I want to play
because she's gonna put the Knight on E6
and I need to kind of play f45 to attack
the Knight if I want to penetrate to the
seventh rank yeah so on so and that
seemed like a very very good plan uh
Rook 2 D7 she managed to defend the
seventh rank but now you're getting
ready to double up and reinforce the
threat of getting on the seventh rank H4
take as much space as possible
where did you feel like you're taking
control of this game
I mean at this point I knew that I'm
better but it's kind of tricky
especially in this time control
uh just one move it can just go the
other way so I was
just be careful that I needed to be
careful to not miss a move or something
like that I mean the Knight and E8 was
passive and this idea b3a4 I really
liked because uh cement the weakness
only five very nice yeah very good
strategical point and G5 and now you're
going to focus on the H7 weakness
and at this point it just felt like her
King was so weak right here yeah this is
Luke swarming around her King this Rook
was tight defense of the Pawn on A5 you
are enjoying your position
I mean yes I was better but I was just
playing you know
each time 23 seconds and 50. yeah that
was kind of stressful I knew that I'm
better but I needed to find a way to get
through and you did indeed find that way
you took that pawn and this is what you
missed this Intermezzo check on F2 after
that you took on C3 two pawns up and you
delivered the full and you took the full
point after that atusa congratulations a
big matchup for you tomorrow you have a
rest day how are you going to enjoy the
wrestling uh I think I'm gonna go
outside and see the city a little bit
yes
and it's nice to have a rest day in
chess tournament so yeah guys any
questions uh our congratulations satucha
big St Louis welcome for you
thank you very much I appreciate it oh
absolutely uh we've got uh well first of
all to refresh our bracket